.
SPEAKING FROM MANY OF NUS NEWS
BUSINESS, IT'S SICKENING EVERY
TIME WE HAVE TO REPORT ON
ANOTHER MASS SHOOTING.
U.S. GUN SALES CONTINUE TO
SKYROCKET.
THE NUMBER OF GUNS PRODUCED HAS
DOUBLED EVERY YEAR.
IN 2020 THERE WAS 600 MASS
SHOOTINGS AND OVER 11 MILLION
GUNS MADE.
THE NUMBER OF GUNS PRODUCED
DOUBLES EVERY YEAR FROM 2010 TO
2020.
SO, OUR QUESTION, THIS DEBATE IS
DO MORE GUNS REALLY MAKE US
SAFER.
IN THE WASHINGTON POST,
COLUMNIST SAYS IF GUN ADVOCATES,
A GROUP THAT INCLUDES THE ENTIRE
GOP ARE CORRECT AND STATED
ASSERTION THAT MORE GUNS MEANS
MORE SAFETY, SHOULDN'T WE BE
ENJOYING A PARADISE OF SECURITY
WITH CRIME PLUNGING TO NEVER
BEFORE SEEN LOWS?
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S NOT WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
JOINING ME IS CNN POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR SCOTT JENNINGS.
SCOTT, I WANT TO START WITH YOU
ON THE HEELS OF THAT OP-ED.
AS A MEMBER OF THE GOP, I'LL LET
YOU RESPOPDS.
DO YOU THINK MORE GUNS MEANS
MORE SAFETY?
>> I THINK THERE ARE PEOPLE IN
THE UNITED STATES WHO BELIEVE
THEY NEED A GIVE UP FOR THEIR
OWN PERSONAL SAFETY.
IT'S ONE OF THE MOST COMMONLY
GIVEN REASONS WHEN YOU DO
SURVEYS OF GUN OWNERS ANDIT'S
FOR PERSONAL SAFETY.
WHETHER YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE MICRO OR INDIVIDUAL RIGHT TO
OWN GUNS VERSUS THE MACRO
STATISTICS IS PART OF THIS
DISCUSSION.
AS A REPUBLICAN, AS A
CONSERVATIVE, IF YOU SUPPORT THE
SECOND AMENDMENT THEN YOU
SUPPORT EVERY INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHT
TO BEAR ARMS.
IF THE REASON IS FOR PERSONAL
SAFETY THEN THAT'S A PROTECTED
RIGHT.
>> SHANNON, GUN PRODUCTION HAS
NEARLY TRIPLED OVER THE PAST 20
YEARS.
WHAT THE YOU SAY TO SCOTT WHO IS
SAYING THIS IS PEOPLE WANTS TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES AS CRIME IS
SURGING.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
WHY DO YOU THINK THERE'S SUCH
INCREASE IN DEMAND?
>> I THINK WHAT SCOTT AND I BOTH
AGREE ON IS THERE SHOULD BE
STRONGER GUN LAWS IN PLACE.
WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
MANY OF OUR VOLUNTEERS ARE GUN
OWNERS OR PARTNERS ARE GUN
OWNERS IN IS ABOUT RESTORING
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT SHOULD GO
ALONG WITH GUN RIGHTS.
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS AS A
FULL-TIME VOLUNTEER FOR A
DECADE.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT GUN EXTREMISM
HAS REALLY TAKEN ROOT IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
IT STARTED OUT WITH THE ARMED
EXTREMISTS SHOWING UP AT
MEETINGS AND THEN STATE HOUSES
AND AT THE CAPITOL ON JANUARY
6th.
THIS EXTREMISM HAS REALLY BECOME
PART OF THE POLICY PLATFORM.
WE'RE SEEING GUN MANUFACTURERS
AND THEIR ALLIES TRY TO ROLL
BACK THINGS LIKE A BACKGROUND
CHECK ON EVERY GUN SALE OR GUN
SAFETY TRAINING.
THIS CRIME WAVE THAT WE'RE
SEEING IS THE LOGICAL OUTCOME OF
HAVING 400 MILLION GUNS IN A
COUNTRY WITH TOO FEW GUN LAW.
TO THE POINT OF THAT OP-ED IF
MORE GUNS AND LESS GUN LAWS MAKE
US SAFER, WE WOULD BE THE SAFEST
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
WE HAVE A 25% HIGHER HOMICIDE
RATE THAN ANY PURE NATION.
THE SITUATION IN BUFFALO, THERE
WAS AN ARMED GUARD THERE.
UNFORTUNATELY, A GUARD WITH A
HANDGUN IS JUST NO MATCH FOR A
WHITE SUPREMISTS WHO HAS BEEN
RADICALIZED ONLINE AND
BALLISTICS GEAR.
IT'S NOT GOING TO PLAY OUT THAT
WAY IN THE REAL WORLD.
>> THERE'S A LOT THERE.
SCOTT I WANT TO LET YOU RESPOND
TO THAT.
I WANT TO PICK UP ON THAT
NUMBER.
APPROXIMATELY 400 MILLION GUNS
IN CIRCULATION IN THE U.S.
NEARLY HALF OF ALL THE PRIVATELY
OWNED GUNS IN THE WORLD.
THAT'S NOT EVEN COUNTING SO
CALLED GHOST GUNS.
SCOTT, WHY DOES THE U.S. NEED
ALL THESE GUNS?
IT'S BEEN ENGRAINED IN OUR
AMERICAN CULTURE SINCE THE
FOUNDING, THE CREATION OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO COMMIT THE
CRIMES.
YOU HAVE THE GUNS INVOLVED AND
POLICIES THAT GOVERN THE PEOPLE
AND THE GUNS.
ONE OF THE THINGS I'VE BEEN MOST
CURIOUS ABOUT IS WHY THE STATE'S
EXISTING LAW, THE POLICIES IN
PLACE DIDN'T STOP THE PERSON
FROM HAVING A GUN.
NEW YORK HAS RED FLAG LAW.
HE SPENT TIME IN A MENTAL HEALTH
FACILITY.
HE HAD BEEN FLAGGED BECAUSE HE
EXPRESSED VIOLENT THOUGHTS.
WANTED TO MURDER SOMEONE AND
COMMIT SUICIDE.
THIS WAS A CASE TAYLOR MADE WHEN
REGULAR FLAG LAWS WERE
CONTEMPLATED.
IN THIS CASE I THINK LESS ABOUT
THE GUN ITSELF AND MORE ABOUT
THE PERSON WHO HAD EXHIBITED
VIOLENT BEHAVIOR AND THOUGHTS,
BEEN IN A MENTAL INSTITUTION FOR
A PERIOD AND THE POLICY THAT
DIDN'T WORK.
HE ALSO PASSED A BACKGROUND
CHECK WHICH MAKES ME WONDER,
WHAT IS IT ABOUT THE POLICIES
AND THE MATRIX OF POLICIES THAT
FAILED.
AS I HAVE CONTEMPLATED THIS
HORRIFIC SHOOTING, THAT'S WHAT
I'VE BEEN WONDERING ABOUT.
THIS GUY FELL THROUGH THE CRACK
AND HE HOW OLD NOT HAVE BAS SHO
THE LAWS IN PLACE.
>> WHAT THE YOU SAY TO THAT SHAN
NON?
>> GO BACK DO WHAT SCOTT WAS
SAYING ABOUT THE CONSTITUTION
AND HOW WE HAVE SOMETHING NO
NATION DOES, THE SECOND AMOUNT.
WE ALSO HAVE A GUN LOBBY WHICH
THEY DON'T HAVE.
WE HAVE GUN MANUFACTURERS THAT
WORK LARD TO INFLUENCE THE LAWS
PASSED BY LAWMAKERS WHO ARE
BEHOLDEN TO THEM.
THAT'S CHANGED THE LANDSCAPE OF
GUN USE IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE FACT THE GUNMAN WAS 18 YEARS
OLD AND LEGALLY BUY A LONG GUN
IN THE STATE OF NEW YORK, I
THINK IS EGREGIOUS.
WE'RE SEEING THE GUN LOBBY TO
LOWER THE AGE TO BUY A HANDGUN.
WE KNOW IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
ABOUT 18% OF ALL GUN HAD HADS
ARE COMMITTED BY MOSTLY MEN AGES
18 TO 22.
THERE ARE ONLY 4% OF POPULATION.
THERE'S AN ISSUE.
I WILL ALSO GO BACK TO WHAT
SCOTT SAID ABOUT THE RED FLAG
LAW WHICH I KNOW BOTH HE AND I
SUPPORT FULLY.
RED FLAG LAWS ARE ONLY AS USEFUL
AS THE WAY THAT THEY ARE
IMPLEMENTED.
WE DO NEED THE MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN A LAW IS PASSED THAT POLICE
AND CITIZENS KNOW THAT IT'S
AVAILABLE.
NAY KNOW HOW TO USE IT.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS
WHITE SUPREMACISTS WAS NOT
ADJUDICATED MENTALLY ILL.
HE HAD NOT BEEN CHARGED WITH
CRIME.
THERE ARE ALMOST ALWAYS WARNING
SIGNS WHICH IS WHY WE PASS RED
FLAG LAWS IN NEARLY 20 STATES
AND WASHINGTON, D.C.
THEY WORK.
THEY ARE CONSTITUTIONALLY SOUND
AND SHOULD BE IN PLACE AT A
FEDERAL LEVEL.
>> WE HAVE SEEN A NUMBER OF
SHOOTINGS WHERE A PERSON WITH
GUN DID NOT STOP THE SHOOTING
LIKE IN BUFFALO AND PARKLAND.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE BACKGROUND
CHECK AND THE RED FLAG LAWS NOT
STOPPING THE SHOOTING BUT AT THE
SAME TIME THERE'S A SECURITY
GUARD WHO LOST HIS LIFE WHO DID
NOT STOP THE SHOOTING.
IF MORE GUNS MAKE US SAFER AS
REPUBLICANS ARGUED, WHY HAVEN'T
THE SHOOTINGS BEEN PREVENTED?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY IN THIS
CASE.
I KNOW WHAT HE WROTE IN HIS
MANIFESTO IS HE WAS HOPING THE
GUN LAWS WOULD MAKE IT EASIER TO
COMMIT THE ATROCITY BECAUSE THE
FACT PEOPLE COULDN'T OPEN CARRY
WOULD MAKE IT HARDER STOP HIM.
THAT'S HIS WORDS, NOT MINE.
I THINK EVERYBODY WANTS TO STOP
EVERYBODY ALL THE TIME FROM
DOING THESE BAD THINGS.
I THINK PART OF THE ISSUE IS
THESE ARE INDIVIDUAL SITUATIONS.
THE WAY THE PEOPLE AND GUNS
INTERACT IS DIFFERENT FROM STATE
TO STATE.
AT THE CORE OF THIS IT'S EVIL
PEOPLE
.
IF WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET STUCK
IN THE MUD, WHERE WE'LL HAVE TO
FOCUS IS ON POLICIES THAT
PROTECT THE CITIZENS BUT STOP
THE VIOLENT PEOPLE WHO CLEARLY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN FLAGGED.
IT USUALLY DOES IN CONGRESS AS
WE HAVE SEEN OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
FRP WHAT I HEARD FROM YOU WHEN I
KNOW ABOUT YOUR WORK, YOU DON'T
WANT TO TAKE AWAY GUNS.
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE GUNS DON'T
END UP IN THE WRONG PERSON'S
HANDS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY THAT IT'S ABOUT
PERSON AND NOT THE GUN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> THERE IS WHERE WE PART WAYS.
THIS IDEA THAT NOTHING THE STOP
A CRIMINAL FROM GETTING HOLD OF
A GUN IS A FALLACYFALLACY.
MANY OF THEM COME FROM BEING
STOLEN.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR A
DECADE.
WE ARE ALL ONLY AS SAFE AS STATE
WITH THE WEAKEST GUN LAWS.
THERE'S SOME REPORTING THAT THE
WHITE SUPREMACIST GUNMAN WENT TO
ANOTHER STATE TO GET A HIGH
CAPACITY MAGAZINE.
HE LIVES RIGHT NEAR
PENNSYLVANIA.
WE NEED FEDERAL LAWS IN PLACE
THAT WILL KEEP US ALL SAFE.
WHEN WE LOOK AT STATES AND THIS
IS SOMETHING OUR ORGANIZATION
DOES, STATES WITH STRONG GUN
LAWS HAVE LESS GUN DEATH AND
STATES WEAK GUN LAWS HAVE MORE
GUN DEATH.
MOST OF TH